thank you
[Music]
in Sudan an outbreak of violence has
killed and injured hundreds of people
and could be the start of civil war it's
just one of many conflicts being waged
across the globe from Ethiopia to
Myanmar to the Democratic Republic of
Congo
around the world wars are getting worse
in the mid-1980s the average ongoing
conflict had been raging for about 13
years by 2021 it was nearly 20.
one reason is the erosion of global
Norms take Russia a permanent member of
the U.N security Council yet it brazenly
violated the un's charter when it
invaded Ukraine in Sudan hardly anyone
has been punished the Mass Slaughter and
rape of civilians during the country's
various Wars but impunity isn't the
whole story here's why
oh
[Music]
you're seeing more and more Wars where
there's more than one Insurgency in the
same country there's roughly tripled
since 2000 and the number of Civil Wars
where there's a foreign power meddling
has gone up 12-fold since the end of the
Cold War to a nearly half of them
[Applause]
so all this makes it harder to to end
the wars because if you've got multiple
armed groups fighting it's really
difficult to come up with a compromise a
peace deal that pleases all of them and
the ones who aren't happy are likely to
go back to fighting with the foreign
powers the problem is that they're not
bearing all the costs of what's going on
it's not their cities that are being
bombed so they don't have the same
urgent incentive to make peace as more
local groups do
and then you're seeing as America has
become completely obsessed with the
China and Russia it's retreated from
other parts of the world and
medium-sized Powers have filled the
vacuum
Sudan's a good example you've seen Egypt
getting involved on one side and the
militia boss who's trying to take over
the entire country is is best mates with
Wagner the Russian mercenary firm
[Music]
almost all these Civil Wars are taking
place in countries where if you're in
power you get to steal a lot of money so
that gives people a motive to rebel and
you're also seeing lots of Rebel groups
are able to sustain themselves by
looting minerals Timber all kinds of
things like that and the
internationalization of organized crime
is making it easier for them to launder
their profits a terrible example is the
Democratic Republic of Congo where there
are multiple groups fighting
the soldiers on the government side are
paid an utter pittance if they're back
in the capital but they can become rich
if they go to the front line just by
being able to extort money out of people
and embezzle supplies at the same time
Rebel groups are able to extort money
from Miners and loggers and launder
their gold out through neighboring
countries and this makes the war pretty
much self-perpetuating
[Music]
was almost all taking place in hot poor
countries and when you have droughts or
floods or unusually high temperatures
you find that a lot of farmers and
herders can no longer make a living on
the land they're on so they move with
their cattle to the neighboring land and
very often they find themselves
encroaching on the territory of people
from other ethnic groups that may be
hostile to them
climate change is making a difference in
in lots of parts of the world from
Myanmar to Syria to even Pakistan
but the place where you really see it is
in the Sahel one study in one sub-region
of Mali by the International Rescue
committee found no fewer than 70
conflicts had broken out over things
like land and grazing you add that up
across a whole region like the Sahel and
it makes it fertile ground for jihadist
groups and insurgencies of all sort the
jihadists say things like we'll bring
you divine Justice and they may get
explicit that they mean you'll get your
pasture land back from the other tribe
the rapid spread of jihadist groups
across Africa and the Middle East in the
past decade or so makes it harder to end
Wars for a couple of reasons their
demands are often Fantastical and
impossible to meet
um they their followers are incredibly
motivated and fanatical and the
atrocities that they commit the suicide
bombings make people like un
peacekeepers hunker down inside their
bases and that means it's very difficult
for them to win the trust of the locals
and ultimately to create peace
peacemaking is very hard
in the short run there's a few things
that seem to work you can start talks
long before the belligerents say that
they're ready to do so do them in secret
that's that's worked in South Africa and
Northern Ireland places like that alas
you have to include bad guys in the
political settlement as well because if
you don't they tend to go back to
fighting you could include more women in
Civil Society groups in the peacemaking
process where that happens peace tends
to last longer and you can experiment
with what works in Liberia for example
they found that reforming the police
meant that the police didn't bully young
men as much and the young men were less
likely to join Rebel groups in the long
run the things that matter most are
building institutions that people trust
and dealing with climate change but
those both those things are going to
take decades in the short run we're
entering an era wherein hot poor
countries life is short and war is long
to read more about why Wars are getting
longer please click on the link and
don't forget to subscribe thank you for
watching